okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is Peter
Richards I will be chairing the meeting
this evening uh some housekeeping we've
made to start with we're not expecting
that to be a fire alarm so if one does
go off please follow us uh slowly out
towards the car park
um Over The Road next to the pub
um we will need to check your names off
uh before you uh head off uh back to
your your own home so if you wouldn't
mind just making sure you do go over
there and get your name checked off so
we can make sure everyone's out of the
building safely that'll be great
um mobile phones if you could please
turn them off or at the very least of
Silence I do appreciate sometimes there
is a need for an emergency message now
and again so at the very least silent
but preferably off as long as they don't
interfere with the flow of the meeting
and that will be fine the meeting itself
is a meeting in public it is not a
public meeting so only those people that
are registered to speak will be
permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I will call you forward to one of
the array of microphones in front of you
um you will notice we do have some new
AV kit um it will be the button on the
right of the uh whichever microphone you
choose it will go red as you can see
here and if you stay around about us
about a handsworth away and speak out
the microphone it will pick you up much
better
um I will of course give you a a warning
before your time is up but we'll talk
about that as and when we bring you
forward
um okay uh let us go through some
introductions if I may start with so on
my far right we have Howard Allison from
our community services uh Team to my
immediate right we have Amy Shipley who
is our solicitor and our plan is no
particular order are Joe Brook Emma
Booker Mal we need zek and Alice cosnet
Alice is our planning manager and I
believe has a statement to make
thank you chairman my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking
thank you very much indeed okay do we
have any apologies for absence please
yes chair we have apologies from
councilors Foreman councilor hedge
serifin and councilor Perry
thank you very much and members do we
have any disclosures of Interest please
Council Mills first yes thanks Mr
chairman
um on the um first application here our
application uh foreign agenda
um I'll be sitting out on that Mr
chairman and also on the last one
um eight on the agenda for warmington
I'm the county councilor for this award
but um I haven't made any handy
conversations with anybody on this so
I'm approaching this with an open mind
Mr chairman lovely stuff thank you very
much councilor Curtis
thank you um item number five on the
agenda two two zero three four one four
um I've had a site made a site visit
I've read all the objections from
various residents I've had a number of
conversations with residents as well
um but I've also had advice from the
monitoring officer I spoke to shortly
before the meeting and I assured him
that I was pretty non pre not
predetermined and that he was happy for
me to take part in the debate and the
meeting
understood thank you very much anyone
else
no in that case minutes is everyone
happy with the minutes from the 25th of
January
yeah marvelous I'll sign those later on
right let's move to our first
application of the evening then which is
application reference
21.03858 ful lands south of Kyneton Road
in Gayden our presenting officer is Joe
Brook Joe over to you
thank you chair
the applications are is located on the
edge of Gayden as indicated by the black
dot before you
the application of proposing the
development of 23 dwellings as sat out
in the officers report 16 of the
dwellings will be designated as local
need dwellings with an additional seven
dwellings as open market properties
the application site is considered to be
outside to build a variable injury as if
detailed in the report and was
originally included in the site
allocation plan but still subsequently
removed because of harm to the listed
building
so as a plan before you that is the
application site in Redline boundary the
development there is Edge Hill View
kyton Road and newly Darwin Edge Hill
view into the application site the
listed building is great to is the leads
located to the north
this is the site layout as proposed as
you can see Edge Hill
Edge Hill view comes into the site area
you have a parking area situated to the
front of the arcade of the private road
coming in a Suds allocation will be the
situated in this location the open
market housing will be to the south of
the solid facing the open Countryside
and a public open space will be located
to the West uh east of the site in
additionally this is about area boundary
of Gaiden as defined in the draft set
and also in their draft NDP
this is a Google Earth for the image
just for members
um
information so at the minute this is the
application site the majority of it is
being used as a site compound for the
development of their chill view but
there is no law for advanced difficult
application so it has to be treated as
open Countryside this is all detailed in
the report the application will extend
if permitted to this area but this will
be the open space area this building is
the lead which is grade two listed
unassociated Gardens
this plan indicates where the housing
mix is going to be so housing Associated
rent is going to be situated within red
to the front of the site the shared
ownership is in green so located on near
the barringes of Gaiden build pero
boundary and also type G housing which
is also part of the shared ownership
owner occupier at discount sale and the
African has confirmed that that will be
obliged for section 106 will be situated
within blue and then the open market
units obviously facing the open
Countryside and they are in pink
foreign this is a design of the
dwellings uh fundamentally the 23
drowners will be constructed are to a
mix of red brick white rendering gray
roof slate and will be set from 5.9
meters these are the bungalows
to 8.8 meters in height for two stories
a rick Soldier courser opposed over the
windows with some brick arches with
brick Sills the dwellings would also
incorporate a mixture of fronted Gables
however this is mainly to the two-story
dwellings open-ended Gables and hip
roofs well it's a two-story hoses are
proposed with chimneys and front door
canopies
she quickly run through the design so
here's more indicative images the
two-story in the bungalows
and finally The Bungalow and also a
two-story element with a sub down
so this is the compound side a minute as
you can see is gated off for Access but
the site is still relatively open
um which shows there is some hard
standard area but
lawfully that is open Countryside
this is actual view which is directly
adjacent to the site so you can see on
the Google Earth image where it is
coming down and the properties and how
they are representative of the proposed
Islands
this is the grade two Lees so that is
circled in red there which would adjoin
the boundary white rendered thatched
roof
this is the Lee's Garden area
development would be situated through
that sort of opening there
and this is then right up to the
boundary of the lead the open space
element would be located along here with
the residence adamant is coming into
there
a nice actual view that you can see in
the outline
and this is taken from the public
footpath of the prowl which is down to
the side of the site so I said chill
view on the development would Encompass
most of that area indicatively
and that's the end of presentation in
summary I sat on the officer report
there are five reasons for refusal and
as such the application is considered
not to meet an identified Community need
is not truly community-led and would
result in an unwarranted development of
seven open market dwellings which
overall would cause undue harm to local
landscape beyond the settlement boundary
again and less than the substantial hard
towards the higher end of the setting
and the grade two listed building
furthermore the criminal parking and the
parking for plot 7 and 23 is considered
to cause undue harm Cherryville design
and layout of the scheme insufficient
information Hazard also not been
provided in respect to visitor parking
visitors plays visibility displays and
Surfer surface water drainage the
application is therefore considered to
be contrary to the policy separations of
the areas development plan
I will also mind members to look at the
update sheet because they are a number
um the request for the substitute Ward
member
the submission of additional information
which me as acting case officer is
refused to accept
Clarity over the independent viability
assessment for basically there was a
viability report committee which was
independently assessment of sun and
young and there's also an update to the
conclusion section which identifies
further arms of the grade two listed
building
and that is itcher
Joe thank you very much indeed members
it's obviously quite a substantial
update have you all had an opportunity
to read it
yeah marvelous in that case we will call
our first Speaker of the evening who is
councilor Adrian Classen of Gayden
Parish Council good evening sir
and welcome
um now as I said earlier on uh you will
have three minutes I will give you a 30
second warning now unfortunately I did
have a button that used to make a noise
but I think I've overused it and they've
disabled it today so
um I will have to speak over you but um
as soon as you're already comfortable
and settled the time will be yours okay
um item one the parish council fully
supports this application as it as it
fully satisfies the needs of the recent
housing survey housing needs survey that
was carried out by the parish council
um
item two the majority of the objections
are from the residents of Edge Hill view
phase one who were always aware that the
phase what phase two was on the cards
item three further objections from the
highways and floodings Authority have
been addressed and unofficially accepted
by those authorities however the
authorities have been denied the
opportunity to accept them officially
um by the planning department
therefore if the committee is not minded
to accept this application on the
current information we request that the
decision be deferred until the committee
is in possession of the latest
information
I can confirm that as well within your
three minutes so thank you very much
members do we have any questions do you
have any questions for our Parish
Council representative
no in that case Council collection thank
you very much your time contribution
this evening
okay we'll move to our next speaker who
is Julian Hardwick
good evening
so Mr Hardwick um in the same way you'll
have three minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning before time is up
otherwise whenever you're settled come
from ready to go the floor's yours thank
you chair
I'm here to speak on behalf of Catherine
de sukis who owns the Lee's Gaiden and
who's one of the many objectors to this
application
the lease is a grade two listed thatch
cottage which dates from the late 1600s
or early 1700s
it is situated on the edge of the
village and is a significant feature of
the community
the proposed development abuts The
Garden of the leaves on two sides in
close proximity to the cottage itself
as you can see from the plan which I
hopefully is going to be shown to you
which is uh one that done I have taken
from the planning application and mended
to highlight the location of the Lees
and the Lee's Garden in relation to both
the proposed development and the
existing phase one development
I I I think that you can see from that
just how dominant this proposed
development would be
the whole of the proposed development uh
is on what is currently uh open
Countryside outside the built up area
boundary of Gayden
uh the photograph which I think you're
going to see in a moment is taken from
the garden of the leaves and shows the
area which the proposed development
would cover
two separate completely objective
Heritage assessments have concluded that
a development on this site would cause
considerable harm to the leaves the
first of these was by personal
Consultants on behalf of Stratford
District Council which resulted in the
whole site being removed from Stratford
council's site allocation plan
the second was undertaken by Stratford
District Council conservation in its
comments on the specific planning
application
I draw your attention to their
conclusions which are quoted on page 19
of the planning of the agenda and which
highlight the adverse impact this
proposed development would have
allowing the developer to this scale
would clearly be contrary to provisions
of the national planning policy
framework by causing the upper level of
less than substantial harm to the
setting of the grade 2 listed building
moreover there are a large number of
additional grounds for refusing this
application
while it purports to be a community-led
scheme to meet local needs it it fails
the key tests for such a development
it has been strongly criticized by
Stratford council's development and
policy enabler officer as you'll have
seen in the planning officers report
although Gayden Parish did not object
the application
until this evening it has only given it
very lukewarm support
and I would just comment that although
many of the the the the objectives uh of
whom there are significant number 24
letters of objection compared to just
five in support uh certainly were aware
aware that uh a phase two was was
proposed uh that the the scale of the
proposal is significantly greater than
they were led to believe
uh this um it cannot given the scale of
local of opposition it cannot be
considered to be a community-led scheme
and in the context of a small village
like Gayden there is no way that a
development of 23 dwellings can be
regarded as small scale
it is clear that in reality this is an
attempt to engineer an open market
Housing Development by dressing it up as
a local housing need
the applicant has been trying for
several years to build on this site to
extend his earlier commercial housing
development called Edge Hillview phase
one situated to the West
indeed the name given to this
application it's your view phase two
completely gives the game away about the
applicant's true intentions
his plan features seven open market
houses situated in unsport Countryside
and outside the settlement boundary
which is completely contrary to planning
policy
moreover this is in a village which has
no need for any such additional
dwellings given the available land
Supply
I endorse everything the planning
officer has said in his recommendations
and Report which amount to a damning
indictment of this whole application
I hope very much that this committee
will endorse his conclusions and refuse
the application
thank you for taking the time to listen
to my presentation
thank you very much indeed for that and
I'm going to have to make an apology I
said three minutes whereas in fact you
did have six and you have you have
extended over the three but you are well
within the six so I just thought I'd
make that clear for everyone thank you
very much apologies for that um do we
have any questions members
no in that case thank you very much for
your time and contribution thank you
okay and our final speaker on this item
is Mr Peter Frampton our agent
foreign
thank you chairman I doubt there is
anybody in this room with a housing need
I envisage we all live comfortably in
our homes for those with a housing need
every day is a misery not being able to
settle in a community not being able to
settle children into schools living in
inadequate accommodation Relentless
stress is caused the parish council has
just made clear that this proposal fully
meets the parish's identified need the
policy test of the support of the local
community is set out in the development
requirements SPD its state schemes must
have the support of the local community
edest the parish council the test is not
as suggested in the planning officers
report of Community Support absolute
sadly in all communities there are those
who do not want any more houses so
absolute support is an unreasonable bar
for satisfying the requirement of
community support and is not required by
planning policy this report does not
bring to your attention National
planning policy for Rural Housing
introduced after the adoption of the
core strategy namely the framework power
77 which states local planning
authorities should note the imperative
support opportunities to bring forward
rural exception sites that will provide
affordable housing to meet identified
local needs and consider whether
allowing some Market housing on these
sites would help facilitate this so the
core strategy is not consistent with
up-to-date National policy which is a
significant material consideration
the applicant has provided the council
as you've heard from the planning
officer additional information the
applicant has responded to the comments
raised by Avison young based on bills of
quantity to support the robustness of
the viability appraisal your officer is
presently declined to action the
consultation process with this
additional information and I note in the
report some comments are made on the
detail detail of the layout I'm advised
that these two can be readily addressed
this is not a speculative application it
is purposely presented for planning
permission to identify to meet an
identified need a fundamental
requirement of the planning system the
framework at 56 says it is important
that the needs of groups with specific
housing requirements are addressed so
I'm making an unusual request to the
committee this evening and that is
twofold one the consideration of this
application is deferred to enable your
officer to progress the consultations to
a site visit is held so members can
inform their own judgment of the impact
of housing upon the significance of the
lays as a listed building the planning
balance can thereafter be undertaken as
to where the overall public interest
lies at a later committee meeting with
hopefully all Technical and design
issues settled and your last speaker
said there was no housing need clearly
that is not correct from the comments
made on behalf of the parish council
thank you chairman thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our agent please
no in that case Mr Frampton thank you
very much time contribution this evening
okay let's move to punch clarification
to our officers councilor Crump first
please
thank you Mr chairman um Joe can I just
confirm that the there are several
objections that are still valid in terms
of the county highways
um the college is not valid now that's
that's removed hasn't it
um the flooding Authority
uh um the development and policy enabler
as well as policy and conservation
allows one still still valid please yeah
yeah on the information that has been
assessed all those are valid objections
to the application
highways out of Aiden policy noon
officer and the STC policy
Council Harvey please
thank you Mr chairman
um
two questions there are 24 letters of
objection and there are five letters of
support can you tell us the degree to
which those are residents of of Gayden
or whether they are from further afield
is one question and second question I'd
really appreciate some guidance on
um
the parish council has now
indicated its full support for the
application
what is the test given given there are
24 letters of objection what is the test
that I should apply in assessing whether
there is community support for this
application
so in response to the first question I
can't conclusively tell you whoever with
where they are or forming Aid and the
honest truth in all applications anybody
anywhere can comment on the application
we still have to take that into
consideration and support or objections
for whatever relevant planning reasons
they submit so I can't conclusively say
one way or the other on that
in respect to the second question
one I should highlight that's the first
time that gay and Paris Council have
conclusively supported the scheme as you
can see in the officer's report they on
two consultation responses did recommend
support but wanted the the application
heard at planning committee
secondly the best way to probably set
out the tests then is if it is truly
community-led is actually set out by the
policy and neighbor officer in the
principal section let me just get that
up
two pages
do apologize
so it is pretty much under the free
tendency is correct that at times the
Paris Council offered full support then
that could be undertaken as full support
from a community-led scheme which is set
on the SPD requirements however at the
same time
the cover letter stated at that time it
was meant to they wanted to be heard at
planning committee and therefore it was
given moderate weight it is also noted
that the written um
character was planning commit due
concerns and seven Oak Market dwellings
they've also got to verify that the
proper consultation has then been
undertaken so
if the parish council at the time were
asking to come planning committee the
SPD then requires the enabling officer
States the proper consultation with a
local public has taken place that was
that was never truly satisfied so at
that point you've then got moderate
weight given to the Paris council's
response because they offer support but
recognize parishioners concerns over it
and wishes it can planning committee
then you've got to make sure that proper
consultation has taken place
that was never truly satisfied at the
same time we've then got to take into
account how many objections to the
scheme have been submitted and how many
have been supported so you're doing a
whole balancing exercise and all those
elements now I appreciate the Paris
Council has showed up tonight and
offered full support but the honest
truth is it's then got to be a waiting
exercise if you believe the Paris
Council full support now overrides the
objections raised for this application
I would love to leave that to members to
decide whoever that is the case
if I can just come in I completely
concur with what Joe has advised there
um the very simple way of putting it in
terms of what the development
requirements SPD requires so it's power
test which relates to this type of
Housing and it says that um a parish or
town for counts oh sorry parish and town
councils can start this game blah blah
blah the support of the local community
will ordinarily be demonstrated by the
written support of the town or Parish
Council or a neighborhood plan so in
normal cases we would say that
constituted the support of the parish
and and the community as a whole but
it's just those reasons that Joe set out
that that has moderated that that
support
uh councilor Dixon first please
thank you chairman
um
has National planning policy changed at
all regarding the provision of open
housing to support affordable housing if
affordable housing can't be justified on
economic grounds has anything nationally
changed in that regard
so
Mr Francis absolutely right the national
parks he does stay that but at the same
time National policy states that you
have to be in accordance with the areas
development of time-led policies the
areas development plan of policies and
policies and set out in the core
strategy so unless there was a material
significant consideration to override
and plant that policies we do not have a
support and policy to have open market
housing even with the local needs
element and this has been further
identified by SDC policy and the policy
enabling officer and that is in in
legislation we have to follow the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
can I just follow on from that if I may
I presume like a material consideration
May well be the viability report which
is why we've had that and it has been
assessed absolutely marvelous thank you
very much uh councilor Curtis next
please
thank you chair
um
Joe you you had a photo showing the view
of the development from the Lee's house
could you just bring that back up
uh well actually that one can you just
for clarification is this development
on the patch that is green in that photo
or on the brown land further Beyond
Scarface well development is but there
will be open space for on that green
patch so let me just go back to the the
better plan to be honest is the actual
location plan so here there's a good
plan so that the green open space will
be along that patch there and
development will proceed there so then
you go to
the location plan so this is the Lee's
Garden area so development will take
place on the whole area right as you can
see from there there will be a public
open space between the Leeds building
there so it will become public open
space rather than Farmland which it
currently is I think that is correct
cancer Kendall please thank you chairman
um just a quick clarification um I think
the parish council said they had a uh
housing needs survey done
um
can you clarify a little more there's a
housing needs survey but we're saying
there's no identified need I'm
struggling a little bit there
so no he's not so much the Arizona knee
survey wasn't taken and this is for 16
local news dwellings in the report you
can see there's discrepancy between the
local news dwellings and what's been
provided here even though I appreciate
the applicant as would start
negotiations with tenure and so forth
who's going to occupy him at late at
date
the problem being with it it's not so
much there's not an identified need
you've got seven open market dwellings
to facilitate the open market units and
that's not a policy requirement and also
it's not well it wasn't truly believed
to be community-led for the reasons that
we've discussed before not to be small
scale and to be that so there is an
identified need it's just this doesn't
meet the policy requirement at all
any other points of clarification
members
I've got one if I made you so I can see
on the update sheet that some
information has been submitted and I
think the agent referred to this as that
it hasn't been accepted here
um and you've outlined your reasoning I
can see there you I think you're saying
that there's been a number of amendments
and additional information been
submitted including the availability
report since December 21 how many times
have you had more information submitted
that has required extra consultations
so we've had a number of cons we've done
undertook three detailed consultations
I've accepted a number of amendments and
including one significant practice
amendments which included the viability
report even though officers revise was
to withdraw at that time we then did do
the viability ball and it was stated on
the Proviso that this would be the only
one significant package amendments which
is also highlight that in our
acknowledgment letter that we send out
to the applicants for all applications
it does state that we were negotiate
during the course the application but
it's reinforced by government policy and
guidance is for every effort to be made
to ensure your scheme is acceptable
before submitting through the use of
professional agents online guidance or
pre-application voice where is available
at the same time our website even states
that
pre-application voice should be a store
and also is therefore after only one
round negotiation should be accepted if
necessary it could be more for Majors
but we have done three quite extensive
consultations and this application has
been going on for almost a year and a
half
okay so um I can see there's been three
sets of additional information being
submitted including revised layouts and
more viability assessment details
training strategies they would all need
to go out for Further full consultation
is that correct that is correct
um as I've been highlighted to you the
LFA and possibly highways of will offer
no ejection I haven't had that response
or I can't conclusively say that at the
same time that information was directly
submitted to them all you need to assess
that information and we need to go back
out consultation to make sure there is
no other disreferences so absolutely all
that would require further consultations
understood thank you for making that
clear councilor Dixon please just one
quick one uh chairman if I may
um just thinking that we've had the the
agent uh of the applicant uh also
requesting a deferment of our decisions
um obviously if we didn't defer a
decision this evening and we followed
the officer's recommendation I'm just
wondering if we have an opinion of what
an inspector might say of having
received that request for that deferment
from the agent acting on behalf of the
applicant
um we would not be able to second guess
what a planning inspector may want to
think or say
um I think the questions I've just asked
to our planning officer and the
responses you've got pretty much
explain the position as far as he's
concerned
um does anyone else have any points of
clarification before he moves into the
debate let's open a debate who would
like to kick us off
councilor Adam first please
thanks
uh
the office has been very robust in
explaining his reasons under Fair
questioning
and they're set out in very great detail
in the report and it does seem that
due consideration to reasonable measures
has been given over the length of the
application period
with all that information and everything
that I've seen so far I can't see
anything that outweighs the
recommendation to refuse I think this
this does
pose harm to the listed assets I think
there are issues amount around the the
actual number of properties being
proposed here and and the type of
properties I've
yeah from my point of view it just does
isn't outweighed by anything that's been
said in support of it so I'm quite happy
to propose that we go along with the
officer's recommendation and reviews
thank you very much councilor Kendall
please thank you chairman uh I won't go
on any further I think councilman said
it all for me um
the case has not been made to go against
the officer's recommendation so I'll
second they are proposal to refuse thank
you very much councilor Edmond please I
will be thirding
uh yeah Joe's done a a great job there
it's not
it doesn't fit with our policies and and
we've tried to make it work and it still
hasn't repeatedly so no I think I think
it's
a crumb place
yeah again very briefly
um there's still several objections
outstanding there's anecdotal evidence
that they've been overcome but we
haven't got that evidence in front of us
um and I can only go on the evidence in
front of us and I will be supporting the
officer's recommendation
thank you Council Harvey please again
I'll go along with uh
seconding sorry I go along with the
officer's recommendation but I do want
to make one one particular Point
um
on the basis that this is a local needs
that it has to have local community
support
and under questioning the key word that
came out for me in uh Alice's
explanation was the word ordinarily
and it seems to me in this particular
instance the Parish Council seem to have
been on the fence and actually now got
off the fence in a particular direction
that's fine but there are 24 objections
and in this context 24 seems to me to be
quite large and I think in these
circumstances ordinarily is the key word
so I'm for all the other reasons one
could talk to confined in the report and
that we've heard I I will be voting in
support
thank you very much there's only two of
you haven't spoken don't feel a need to
okay in that case well I I'll just Chuck
my my thoughts in I'm not going to go
over what everyone else has said already
because I can hardly agree but what I
would say is I think Joe has gone out of
his way to be accommodating
um and we still haven't been able to
overcome the statutory objection so I um
I think this is a terrific report on and
uh well put together
let's move to a vote we have a proposal
to refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation it has been seconded by
councilor Kendall could have a show of
hands for those in favor of refusal that
is unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to refuse application 2103 858
ful Land South of Clinton Road in Caden
uh now members I forgot to mention
earlier on that we do in fact have an
item tonight that has no speakers on
which means we can delegate it so um I'm
looking at uh I think it's item six on
our agenda um reference 2203 427 ful and
two two zero two eight four one LBC
um I'm assuming that given well in line
with our constitution with no speakers
that we can move to delegate I'm
assuming everyone's happy with that in
which case we will delegate that both
the LBC and the full application okay
now let's go back to uh application
reference
2203414 ful that is land belonging 212
Clifford Chambers our presenting officer
is Emma Booker as soon as you're ready
Emma uncomfortable the floor is yours
okay thank you
um so before members today we've got an
application a site located in Clifford
Chambers it's for the change of use of
the land to a dog walking facility and
it's a retrospective application because
the site is already in use
so on this plan you can see the boundary
of the application site in red
and this isn't a plan sorry and in pink
the conservation area and then you can
see the list of buildings as well in red
within that Conservation Area you can
see the residential
um built form to the south of the site
and to the north it's bound by the river
stower
so this is the site in the context of
the The Wider area see Stratford town to
the north
we've already seen this one but just to
highlight that the applicant uh also
owns the dwelling on the south um West
and then this little parcel that's in
equestrian use
um it doesn't form part of the
application site
so this is the site plan it's showing
that there is a proposal to formalize
off street parking
um and also maneuverability space as
well so that they can exit or the
customers can exit in a forward gear
you can see that the access is off the
main street in Clifford Chambers
between two neighboring dwellings
so this is an aerial photo
um
just to show the relationship of the
application site with the agricultural
land to the North and the village to the
South
this is just from a different
orientation so you can see the proximity
of the site to the Village
the yellow star indicates where the
customers would be parking
so these are some site photos
um I'm stood on the access track to the
field looking towards Main Street
um the yellow arrow on the on the right
hand side shows the access in between
those two neighbor dwellings
so this is
um as you approach the site this is
where you would enter you can see that
there's a sign saying access by
appointment only
um and there's a there's a login book as
well where customers would sign in
again just more views into that space so
this is where the parking is proposed
these are photos from within the field
where the dogs are able to be let loose
so you can see the boundary treatments
um and that relationship that the site
has with some of the neighboring
dwellings
again more more site photos showing
those boundary treatments
and that concludes the presentation
Emma thank you very much indeed and
let's call our first speaker on this
item who is Council Les Mosley excuse me
uh chairman of Clifford Chambers Parish
Council for Chambers and milk at I
should say Parish Council uh good
evening Council Mosley um in the same
way as everyone else that we've seen so
far you'll have three minutes I'll give
you 30 second warning when you're
comfortable and ready to go the floor is
yours thank you chairman
um I do apologize I may repeat something
that the officers just said uh haven't
I've not been able to witness what you
were about to say
um Burnley this presentation has about
the traffic Generation
Um unreal safety and I'd like to point
out that we haven't yet had a visit from
the highways department so it has been
requested but uh has yet to happen
as councilors can see the parish council
of objected to this application on
several planning grounds this activity
has been ongoing for some time as we've
just heard which the parish council
received numerous complaints about noise
about loose dogs and issued around
Vehicles causing near accidents and
parking therefore we have responded to
the parishioners views by making this
objection
as you've seen Clifford Chambers is a
very small community it's just off the
b4632 The Villages contained mainly on a
single Road known as Main Street
with a number of short Avenues off now
this road is already very narrow and due
to the parking of cars outside
properties with no off-road parking this
makes it even more so
and also being a dead end the road most
visiting Vehicles need to Traverse Main
Street twice an invariably need to give
way to oncoming vehicles I notice your
photograph shot no cars at all outside
the vehicle about outside the houses
next to the access that's a miracle
there are always cars parked outside the
99 of the time there are Vehicles parked
both sides of the road in that location
access to the sizes you've seen
um is very narrow
in fact
um there's hardly room for more than one
vehicle there certainly isn't room for
two vehicles to pass and therefore any
vehicle entering that access
meeting a vehicle coming the other way
which could be one of the residence
Vehicles would have to reverse house
onto the main road
on the turn into the entrance is also in
the narrowest part of the Main Street
and often obstructs it as I've mentioned
by Park Vehicles now during the six
years it's took to produce the
neighborhood plan an area that was
highlighted again and again was the
issue of parking and access along Bain
Street and in an effort to gain
parishionist views and concerns the
neighborhood working party managed to
hold a number of public events each one
was attended by more than 70 people in
all 30 seconds in all of these public
consultation events uh parking was a
major issue
I want to quote the main issue that I
see which is the
um the objective in the neighborhood
plan
the neighborhood plan makes it quite
clear that development proposals should
not compromise Road Safety or increase
congestion within the neighborhood area
particularly along main streets
the parish council therefore asked
councilors to refuse this application
and in doing so we hope that you'll
support the views of parishioners
embodied in the stated objectives of the
made neighborhood plan however based on
the fact that hybridges have gone over
I'm afraid you have gone over your time
there so I'm going to have to stop you
now thank you very much
members do we have any do we have any
questions for our Parish Council Council
Harvey please
um
cancer Mosley um can you tell me how
many accidents there have actually been
along that road
well in in the village itself the
registered number of accidents uh I
don't have um specifically what we have
had is a number of eyewitness accounts
of near misses and one law socyclist
I've been to break and almost fell off
his bike
the issue the issue with that access is
that to come out of it you'll come out
blind
there is no way you can see until you've
brought your car beyond the level of the
two houses that you saw
this means that pedestrians are at risk
um and because of parked Vehicles which
invariably are on both sides of the
access it is impossible to see until you
brought your car three quarters of the
way out of the access and that in itself
we consider to be a very high risk the
fact that I'm going to stop you there I
think you answer the question you know
the question was about accidents rather
than the access itself Castle Crump I
believe you've got a question along
similar lines yeah it's long similar
lines thank you councilor Mosley um
firstly what is the speed limit
um just confirming on that 20 miles per
hour 20 miles an hour and secondly you
mentioned just part of the consultation
of the NDP that was considerable debate
about this uh did you take any
professional advice consultancy
regarding traffic movements
Etc or or yeah that's basically the
question right uh no we didn't at that
time okay
okay any other questions for our Parish
Council
no
in that case councilor thank you very
much for your time contribution this
evening
okay let's move to on next speaker on
this item who is a Mr Martin reason
good evening and welcome now I think
you've probably got an idea of how
things are going to run as soon as your
sat comes from ready you'll have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning and when you are comfortable the
floor is yours
thank you chairman my name is Martin
reason I hold power of attorney for my
elderly parents whose property is
Hampton Cottage Clifford Chambers which
they've owned for over 40 years it's
situated immediately adjacent to the
entrance to River Meadow and has been
adversely affected by the unauthorized
dog walking business which has been
escalating at in scale of activity over
the last two years
I myself and a former resident and I
represent the fellow residents of
Clifford Chambers who have objected to
this application raising a wide range of
planning objections but I will focus on
two main grounds for refusal
the entrance to the site is entirely
unsuitable and there are significant
risks already impacting residents access
from Main Street is narrowed down a
single track which leads to Hampton
Cottage my parents race and River Meadow
at no point is it more than three meters
wide and consequently no vehicle or
indeed pedestrian encountering a vehicle
can pass vehicles and encountering one
another another have to either turn
around in Hampton Cottage causing
trespass
drive or or causing chances or reverse
into the highway at the entrance there
is no splay it crosses a pavement and
has very limited visibility traveling
forwards let alone in reverse the
suggested condition
by the by the planning officer of timed
entrance does not address this this risk
simply because the planning condition
cannot time when residents choose to
travel to or from their own houses
or 14 Main Street an adjacent house
which also has access by the single
track and whose resident is bound in a
wheelchair
secondly the proposed dog walking site
is located in a predominantly
residential location
where residents have every right to
expect to go about their daily lives
without imposed risk from a commercial
business inserted into their environment
what risk am I describing
three properties as I've said are
located immediately on the entrance
itself Hampton Cottage 13 Main Street
and 14 Main Street whether or not you
like dogs the residents of these
properties are at risk every day of
encountering a dog or a vehicle when
leaving or entering their own home in
addition there are over 25 properties
whose Gardens adjoined the site and who
have cited evidence to SDC of
uncontrollable dogs gaining access to
their own properties more generally
local residents have also pointed to the
already congested parking and traffic
flow problems 30 seconds in summary this
application shouldn't be refused not
because we're anti-dog anti-healthy
exercise or anti-commercial development
it should be refused because the site is
located in an inappropriate residential
location where the residents cannot be
protected from potential harm and
because the access route is unsafe
that is why we're objecting and that is
why the parish council are objecting
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions please
no I oh hang on we've suddenly got two
last minute ones Kaza Dixon first please
thank you
uh Mr recent
um just to clarify from my own mind
where your parents reside because
there's residents vehicles on that track
on that plan there are we on the
left-hand side behind the smallish Blue
Area yes that is Hampton Cottage and I
also cited two other properties the
property 14 Main Street which is on the
other side of the track
uh that is the resident in that location
is disabled he hasn't he has disability
he's severely impaired and he's only
access into his own property is via that
track
and he's wheelchair back
you'll see on the screen now there's a
cursor circling number 14 just so you're
clear on exactly where it is Council
Curtis please
oh you're done okay
um I'll have a quick question if I may
so you uh it sounds like there's
activity there already how often or how
many dogs are coming per hour for
example is it constant through the day
are there lots of cars coming in and out
I did submit uh a file of evidence which
was from from my parents camera on the
outside of their house which showed
people turning in the drive
because they couldn't get past meeting
in the drive hiding from each other
um instances where a dog a dog walker
would come
see that he was going to meet a dog
coming the other way go into my parents
drive and hide so that his dog didn't
encounter the other and most of this is
because the people who use these type of
sites have animals which they don't want
to let loose in
we're straying a long way away from the
question I actually asked you which was
how many people roughly are coming per
hour or per day are we talking five or
six cars per hour or are we talking one
or not not per hour but um there will be
instances on one in on one day 16
occurrences I would say the average is
somewhere between seven and eight per
day
um and it can be from early in the
morning till late at night understood
thank you very much that's answered the
question members do we have any other
questions for Mr reason before we let
them go no Miss reason thank you very
much for your time contribution
okay let's call our last speaker on this
item who is our applicant Linda Pollock
good evening Mrs Pollock good evening
uh now you will have six minutes feel
free to use as much or as little bit as
you like again I'll give you three Min
at three minutes a 30 second warning
before your time is up but otherwise
when you're sat ready comfortable
floor's yours
um I have nothing to say except that the
Emma Brooker has put forward a very good
layout of what happens on our land she
asked us to provide photographs we have
um what she has said as we feel it's
been very fair
um and a lot of the objections have
never been made to us by either
Mysteries and or the parish council
there is another close within the
village that is equally as narrow as
ours and has down it now eight plus five
more properties it also is single track
oh just sorry just to confirm there have
been no accidents
lovely thank you that's well within your
time surprisingly
um now if you wouldn't mind saying City
for questions I think we have one from
Castle Curtis to start with please
thank you thank you Linda um can I just
ask if
you would be were the committee minded
to approve that looking at the
additional conditions that the officer
has proposed that you would be happy
with those
more than happy with those
um we did discuss the opening hours
um and the only time they would be of
difficulty is on the recommendation of
Charities and the rspca that dogs are
not exercised during the high heat of
the day which means that they would have
to come after that time
Council Dixon next please
uh councilor Curtis has beaten me to the
subject I'm sorry I'm sorry councilor
Crump please
thank you
there was one of the objectives
mentioned uncontrollable dogs have you
been aware of any incidents of dogs
turned up to your establishment being
out of control or subsequently being out
of control once whilst over there
we do get dogs that have been imported
we do get dogs that have been rescued
and we do get dogs that don't get on
with other people
we do get dogs that come to be trained
as a puppy we get a lot of dogs from a
charity called dog for dogs for good who
we are volunteers for
they come for free that is our part of
volunteering for that charity and
supporting that charity the charity
supports and brings forward dogs that
help children with autism
onset dementia and disabled people in
wheelchairs we provide free dog walking
during the week for them I think I'm
gonna have to stop you because in the
same way that I did for our other
speakers we've strayed a long way from
the actual question you satisfied your
questions being answered can I just have
a follow-up slight follow-up please I
have no been any instance where members
of the public
have been put at risk or by any of these
uh uncontrollable so-called
uncontrollable dogs we had one husky
that took on the fencing
um but I asked him not to come again
because we have a booking system I know
who comes when
we thank you Council Harvey please
can you tell us anything about
um where your dog walkers live and can
you tell us how many arrived by car as
opposed to arrive on foot I would say a
hundred percent arrive by car
um
sadly Clifford Chambers is now on the
dog walking recommendation footpath book
so there are 30 dogs in the village that
walk in the village there are three
Publications that recommend walking in
Clifford Chambers not our field just
walking in Clifford Chambers
and this became apparent during covid we
provided during covid a very strict
system which was recommended by the
government that nobody came from further
than five miles away
happy thank you do we have any oh sorry
counselor Adam you did put your hand up
uh thank you chair um there was some uh
I think it was the parish council
alluded to some cases where the
neighboring properties had dogs in their
Gardens
um could you elaborate if that's uh the
case or not from your your point of view
again as for the previous counselor
there was one case where the dog took on
the fence
um the owner was able to get it back
um we asked him and he also offered not
to come again
the terms and conditions and the
photographs on our Facebook page of the
area
say how high the fencing is there are
other dog walking areas that have six
foot high fencing we didn't feel it was
appropriate for our neighbors to have
that
and by the way we only have five
neighbors not 35 Neighbors
lovely thank you very much members do we
have any other questions for our
applicant
no in that case thank you very much for
your time on contribution this evening
okay let's move into points of
clarification with our officers does
anyone have any points to be clarified
councilor Mills first please thanks Mr
chairman
um I wonder could there's been a lot
made about the uh access to
uh this dog walking area can you
put it up again please on the photograph
and are they
that's the one now
is it going across a pavement or is it
um a drop curb do we know
I'd say that that's both it's a drop
curb and a pavement yeah
but we can't see because the arrow is in
the way isn't it
um oh
there are other photos shall I go to the
ones at the end I I can I can see
through the I can't see through the
arrow obviously but I've got a quite a
close view here it is a drops curve but
obviously a drop curb is on a pavement
so there is a pavement that goes across
but it's a drop curb I think it looks up
to be a half an inch deep if that helps
thank you Mr Chen pleasure Council
Curtis please
thank you chair
um
Emma can you clarify this because a lot
of it has been made of
cause accessing the the dog walking site
um can you just clarify how many
properties are served by this track
so you can see that there's Hampton
Cottage here at the rear
um
and then that would be it I think
I think isn't that two properties
13. yes
so but I suppose my point really chair
is that there are
probably at least a couple of properties
down that track so vehicles are going up
and down that track anyway to serve the
properties yeah that's correct yeah
no problem at all Council Harvey
um
one of the speakers made a pointer
stating that he believed if I recall
correctly that worship County Council
highways had not visited
do you know whether that's the case and
if it if it was the case does it cause
you any concern that an opinion has been
given by the County Council without a
visit
so I can't I can't comment on whether
they have this to the site they don't
usually advise me of that but I think
it's reasonable for them to be able to
assess things with their own system and
not visit every site so if they are
satisfied that they have the information
that they need to assess something just
based off the plans and the speed limit
and things like that I wouldn't have any
grounds to question what they've said
because at the end of the day they are
the expert so
yeah five ounces okay any other points
clarification before I Chuck in with
mine no okay
um so Emma on the I I I'm just trying to
get my head around the conditions so I
know exactly what they mean so condition
of three maximum number of individuals
three and number of dogs four per
booking does that mean that could be
three different people
with three or in this case four separate
dogs so they're not all coming in one
car they're not one group
they are they could be three cars coming
separately
so the management plan will stipulate
that there's one booking and in those in
that one booking it will be three
individuals so they would be part of a
of a party so you know yeah so so it's a
single booking with a maximum number of
three people and four dogs yes okay so
the likelihood it'll be one car per
booking with a maximum stay of I think
it says 60
minutes
yeah so it's my understanding that they
offer 30 minutes and an hour slots
but the condition allows for all of the
slots in one day to be an hour long
um we did we did consider whether it be
appropriate to restrict the number of
cars per booking but it's not really
enforceable or easy to monitor so that's
why that's not been proposed
but it's one booking per slot
so in
one could argue that whilst you've got
three individuals and four dogs per
booking that booking might be for family
and they all might come in individual
cars so it might be three cars
there's there's potential okay
and the grace period 15-minute grace
period that is presumably between
bookings yeah so one slot ends and then
you have 15 minutes for if anything
happens for them people to vacate and
then the next people will arrive at the
end of that 50 minute period so it it's
to mitigate the access being now access
conflicts yeah I understand that hey
thank you very much okay councilor
Curtis yeah sorry Joe thanks for letting
me come back on this
um
yeah there seems to be quite a bit of
ambiguity that's been revealed about the
number of cars and that given that the
the cars seem to be a main objection or
a clear objection
would it be feasible do you think to
have the condition that a booking is a
car a single car because I think that
would
you know could we we could be talking
about the difference between sort of 15
20 car movements a day or five or seven
that's quite a bit of difference it will
be maximum six given there's only six
bookings per day but your point is valid
so we did consider the condition
um when I was drafting this report but
it was on the advice of our enforcement
officer that we don't propose that
condition but in the management plan
which I'm just trying to locate which we
have conditioned I think it stipulates
that it will be one car per booking
so even though it's not an explicit
condition that is something that's
comprised within the management plan so
to manager so just to be clear anyone
wanting to book when they're making that
booking it's clear that it is only one
car per yeah they will be advised to
that so it says here in the management
plan which I are conditioning at number
12 booking slots only allow one vehicle
per booking with a maximum of three
people per vehicle
thank you
um okay I think uh everyone's down with
a bunch of clarification yes let's move
into debate who'd like to kick us off
I'm going to point a finger cancel the
candle please
thank you chairman um I've listened with
interest and I certainly understand the
concerns for residents but as we've just
gone through I think the main concern
does sound like the vehicle movements I
think that's been really well tied down
by the officer here and I just I don't
think it's going to cause the level of
disruption that people fear I understand
the fears that have completely logical
fears to have but I don't think it's
going to cause those uh the traffic
weapons to be particularly difficult at
all so with that in mind I'm in favor of
supporting a you know a local business
so I will propose we Grant the
application
thank you very much councilor Adam
please
oh I saw mirroring the first application
um I'm quite happy to support a second
that proposal I think
uh cancer Kendall outlined that
perfectly I do appreciate the concerns
from the local community but
I'm not convinced that they will be
realized
um as as much as uh as this beard based
on the the work that's gone into to
ensure that so yeah very happy to
support on this one fabulous thank you
Council cases please thank you um
I would be I well reminded sport I think
the conditions are good and what I
wouldn't want to see would be and I I
accept the applicant's concerns that if
it's a very very hot day you shouldn't
take dogs out today but I think
the for residents were reminded to
approve
being certain in the knowledge that
these are the hours from whatever it
says in the conditions eight till five
or whatever and that they are not
variable and I think if it is a very hot
day then I think that's just unfortunate
for the dogs
but I wouldn't want to see that
condition vary for different weather
conditions
I understand what you're saying
um the difficulty for me is that it
feels it seems to me like you're
preempting a future application which is
not what's in front of us to vary the
reality is what we're looking to either
agree to or refuse today has a clear set
of uh timings yes and those are the
conditions good if something comes in
the future as a very we'll look at it
and the merits of it at that stage but
I'm not going to start trying to preempt
unless anyone else wants to dive into
the debates I think we've pretty much
covered everything
um we will go to a vote so the proposal
is to Grant in line with the office of
recommendation gonna have share of hands
please in favor please
that is unanimous so uh committee
therefore is obviously Grant application
2203 414 ful lamb along into 12 Clifford
Chambers
marvelous thank you very much indeed
let's move on to our next item which is
application reference
2203314 fuel garage blocks in Bishops
itchington our presenting officer in
just a moment will be well winner
foreign
has finished breaking all of our new it
uh she I'm sure she'll be ready to go so
my winner as soon as your sat Comfort
I'm ready to go the floor is yours
okay good evening
[Music]
um
so this application is located in
Bishop's itchington it's a former garage
site located within the build up area
boundary
of Bishops itchington the site is
accessed by the existing axis of a
Starboard Road and a public footpath
runs adjacent the Eastern application
site boundary over just over there
um and as you as you can see on this
plan the site is surrounded by
residential dwellings
this is the location of the site in The
Wider contact context
um as you can see
and what is being proposed uh proposed
are
um two three bed detached dwellings
um one with attached garage
serving plot one and another one with a
detached Carriage serving plug two
here you can see the proposed plants and
elevations on the left hand side you can
see
um the proposed dwelling on plot one
with the garage attached
and on the left on the right hand side
you can see
the dwelling proposed on plot 2.
so you can see that the first dwelling
has has a cable to the front and the
second dwelling has to has cables to the
side
and this is the proposed detached garage
to serve the dwelling on plot 2.
and this is the side photograph you can
see the garage's side
um just over there and at the time of my
site visit the garages were demolished
this is the site
[Music]
um
as you can see it is a fan stove
and the public footpath runs adjacent
defense in the rear over there
so the dwellings would
the front elevations would be there
this is the site
um here on the
top photo as seen from the public
footpath you can see the dwellings
in the rear and this photo shows
um
the Aria
to the rear of the dwellings near the
access way
so these are the dwellings
um
near the access way
to the north of the side
and just a little bit of a background
um there was an application for two
dwellings
um four bed dwellings and that was
previously
withdrawn and
there were some issues related to impact
on the residential amenity that have
been addressed by Amendment and it has
been considered that the proposed
dwellings are on balance acceptable and
within their guidelines
that's all thank you
marwina thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is Adam dugmore chairman of Bishops at
Kingston Parish Council
good evening thank you for your patience
I think you know the drill now three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
when you're sat comfortable ready to go
the floor is yours push push the button
on the right
okay good evening everyone
um seven residents have written
objections outlining their legitimate
concerns about the negative impact that
shoehorning these houses in will have on
their residential immunity they have
modest south facing Gardens which they
currently enjoy but they will be
overshadowed by these new dwellings
while the report asserts that the 13
meter separation can be achieved this is
based on the back walls of the upper
story rooms not the ground floor spaces
which extend a few meters closer
reducing this to only 10 or 11 meters
possibly three meters less when one
considers the actual backward the wall
of the garage being proposed on plot one
um the nearest property 19 Starboard
Road will see most of its um source of
daylight from the south blocked by this
no mention has been made through the
application or in the officer's report
of the flooding issues that plague that
particular area the nice little grass
section that was shown earlier on
um is very frequently waterlogged and
sections of the existing hard standing
area has been known to disappear under
six inches or more of water
stub old road today is an outstanding
example of a mismatch between parking
need and provision
it has actually got worse
the garages that have been destroyed
here were built to provide parking to
the residents of Starboard Road the
prospect of Redevelopment to something
other than equivalent or better parking
provision is a failing in the first
place to the detriment of those
residents
the report cites part o of the
development requirements SPD insofar as
it requires two spaces each for these
three bedroom dwellings
it is fantasy to believe that the garage
is there will ever be used to park a car
especially as the officer deems them too
small to also house cycle storage so it
is inevitable that second cars will
litter the street
further he claims that the development
will not increase on-road parking
requirements however the rounding down
of the total .4 visitor space is
required means that all visitors are
assumed to be parking on the street
exacerbating the already very difficult
situation on Starboard Road
the application itself adds nothing very
little to nothing to the parish which is
in fact grown by 482 dwellings in the
core strategy period not the 203 argued
by the report which conveniently can
disregard the 270 to the north of the
village because they're on a Brownfield
site
The Proposal here providing speculative
Residential Properties for which no
housing need has been demonstrated
if the committee is minded to Grant this
application it does so disregarding the
concerns of numerous residents
casting those aside for the gain of
individuals with no apparent
relationship or interest in contributing
to the social or economic fabric of the
village
I was just about to give you a 30 second
warning and you're finished so thank you
very much indeed members do we have any
questions please for our Parish Council
Council Harvey please
all right good evening hello page 65 of
the office of the papers the officers
report makes reference to the nearly
adopted NDP two questions then
um can you tell us where it is in the
process the regulation stays shut and
and
the officer makes a point that the NDP
supports the principle of new Housing
Development within the built-up area
boundary is that the case okay so I'll
take those two questions separately then
so in response to the first one it has
passed a referendum and is due to be
made I believe this week
at your cabinet meeting
and in response to the second question
um yes in respect of that policy you're
correcting that wording however there is
also a policy that requires such
development not to be to the detriment
of residential immunity of adjoining
properties
anyone else with the question
no cancel that thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
okay our last speaker on this item is
councilor Chris Kessel
do you come and sit down councilor
kettle
councilor Crump is having a joke at your
expense but I shouldn't worry too much
about that
um so cancer Kettle you will have your
usual five minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning before your time is up
use as much or as little of that time as
you wish
um otherwise when you're ready sat
comfortable and good to go the floor is
yours
yeah the cattle are having taken great
care to log yourself into that you might
want to press on before you I've managed
to get it working fine
um evening ladies and gentlemen
um
there is design there is good design and
there is appalling design
um this part of the village uh was built
as an estate it's called the lake and
drive estate uh and comprises about four
roads
um of
owner occupied uh through to what were
originally built as Council houses and
this location is uh the area where most
Council houses were built very small
properties mainly terraced
but with a A continuing design from one
end of the lake and drive estate to the
other
um
whilst they're different size
you can see right from the beginning
they all form part of the same estate
what we've got here
on an area set aside for garaging
garages is to completely different
designed properties dropped into a bit
of space crammed in to a bit which was
formally used for car parking
the officer hasn't shown any photographs
of what this part of the lake and drive
state looks like on a Friday evening or
a Saturday
were it is impossible to park without
blocking somebody else in
because
once when this when this estate was
originally built it was clearly
um not that many people had cars now
most properties have two cars and there
is complete inadequate space in this
party estate
for car parking it has been suggested to
the parish council they might like to
build a multi-story car park this is a
serious proposition put forward mainly
because around the lake in driver estate
there is no spare room for parking what
we're doing here is we're taking away
garages some of which were not used for
car parking but sorry Mr chairman you
want there's some weight why do you have
a chat
um I was getting advice from my officers
which is a normal course if you want to
carry on with your bits that would be
great thank you
um I didn't want you to lose my thread
that's all
um
what we lost we lost the car parking
errors uh and what not only that is
we're now going to replace it with more
car parking
um and that is a major major problem
because I can tell you one thing the
sale payment we might not we might get
will not provide a multi-story car park
um other things about the design it's
very clear that garages so it should be
subservient to the main property and yet
one of these garages sitting in front of
the property since when did that become
acceptable it has never been acceptable
but when I was saying it is in this case
because it is behind some other
properties
but every other property the main
building is is not uh well the small the
garage is not subservient it's the main
building and sticks out in front of it
um
so
my concern here is is all about the
design and the car parking
um I pick up Council Doug most common
about flooding there has been
considerable surface water flooding in
this area
um not mentioned in the report at all
this will exasperate the the issue again
um I'm not going to go on any further Mr
chairman if you want to do a decent job
and we have a design guide as part of
our course strategy we have a policy cs9
which is all about good design if we're
going to follow our core strategy please
let's follow our core strategy and not
just accept these things because they
happen to be tucked into a spare corner
of the village it is unacceptable this
design it should not be accepted by this
District Council because otherwise we
might just say let's accept anything
whatever it looks like because it's a
spare bit of ground I will add
Bishops has had
so much more housing than it was
allocated in the original core strategy
and I would remind you in the course
strategy the inspectors report on that
on that core strategy said that the two
thousand houses allocated local service
Villages should give certainty to
developers and residents and that is the
exact word
of what they should expect
in terms of housing numbers
when we are
400 properties
plus because it'll be more than that
actually 400 Properties Plus over the
numbers eradicated then that is uh again
no reason why we should be jamming extra
houses in this patch thank you
do we have any questions for our war
member members cancer Mills first please
hey good evening councilor Kettle um the
garage is who
well they're not there anymore but who
owns the guy did own the garages they're
all but garage and they're all but
garages and the housing there are they
mainly orbit properties all orbit
properties thank you very much
Council cramp please
well I can schedule
um I think Florida news mentioned in the
report on page 70 but I've got a query
for the officer on points for
clarification in a minute so I'll be
mentioning that
um yeah three questions first of all how
long have the garage has been empty
are is there any sign of their
dereliction or disrepair to them and do
any residents currently park in that
disused parking area
the garages before they were sold off by
orbit
um all were allocated to
um orbit residents and under the orbit
agreement they could be given notice and
were given notice some years ago
um to vacate those properties some way
clearly used for non-garaging purposes
they were used for storage
um some were not someone were used for
garaging because that's what they were
designed for
um
they were knocked out I can't quite
remember when they were knocked down
because I don't want my god when they're
knocked down but uh that you know
clearly they were knocked down there
wasn't very good set of repair because
we haven't spent any money on them
um and some of the two were not actually
terribly safe but that does not
um remove the fact that it was an area
allocated for parking for these
properties in the 1970s when the leaking
driver's estate was built I remember it
being built
um and we are with a stroke of a pen at
risk of removing
a really important area of parking for
those residents at this end of the
village
cancer Curtis please oh just bear with
me cancer Curtis sorry councilman you've
got to follow up have you no it's one of
my questions wasn't answered do any
residents currently Park in the distance
parking area
I'm going to work on the basis of the
photo that we've seen shows that they've
been knocked down and it's fenced off
the answer was no that's all right
councilor Curtis please thank you very
much
um thank you councilor
um all of the orbit have removed this
parking provision can you just clarify
whether or not
um orbit made any other provision in
place of these garages that were knocked
down
uh no there were when those garages
disappeared there was the residents were
all the tenants were kicked out of that
area and made park on the street and it
it is a it's quite a narrow cul-de-sac
and if I'm visiting people in that part
of those Villages I know I park and I
block about 10 people in
um and leave you know you can't go into
a house because you know somebody might
want to move out that is how serious the
parking problem is in this area and this
this proposal is going to exacerbate
that's
um considerably it you know it may not
be the greatest things but for the
residents of that part of the village
this is going to create a significant
bigger problem for parking than has
already been the case and it's pretty
bad already
okay councilor Harvey please can I just
ask you good evening Council
um great should actually to explain that
I'm sat here thinking
um whether this particular site is
developed or not
the parking problems that there are in
the in the vicinity are the parking
problems in the vicinity
so could you explain to me how
if consent was given in these two
properties were built could you explain
how you think
the parking problem would be exacerbated
firstly
these are quite significant properties
there's as with most properties of the
size there'll be more than one car
allocated to them and therefore there
will be
um
more cars than the single garage
which we can see on the plan uh will
there'll be a demand progression number
of spaces and they're actually available
on the property therefore those cards
are going to have to go somewhere else
the area that is currently or was
currently the garage area was an area
where people were able to park
now that is no longer going to be
available for that because they're going
to have houses on it so where you know
what is going to happen to that space
it is lost as a facility to the Village
overly satisfied with the answer I mean
has your your question been answered
it's been answered marvelous let's move
on then
um
does anyone else have any questions for
our war member no council thank you very
much your time and contribution this
evening
members let's move to points of
clarification with our officers who
would like to kick us off councilor Adam
first please
thank you chairman um
it was alluded to by the uh Parish
councilor that the
distance from the I think it was plot
one the building itself for the house
was uh met the minimum distance
requirements but that the garage I think
didn't uh are you just able to elaborate
whether that's the case or not please
um yes so
um Part F of development requirements
SPD sets out the minimum separation
distances between
um two-story walls so this is how the
proposal was assessed and on this site
plan you can see that the minimum would
be achieved
quickly I've
uh sorry do you mind if I just see the
um the elevations on the garage
or at least the building that has the
attached Carriage please
so so this would be
um the dwelling plot Number One
and the separation distance was measured
from the two-story wall in accordance
with Part F of the SPD to the two-story
wall
of the neighbor neighboring property
but it's the the Gable of the garage
that's up against the boundary or
adjacent to the boundary
I'm reading that right
yes so
um
yeah no that's all thank you
okay and councilor Harvey please I'm
conscious of the point that councilor
Kettle made about the predominance of
terrorist former Council housing in the
area
I'd like if you can to tell me how many
other instances of houses of this sort
of design are present in the vicinity of
Bishop Edgington
um so looking at the photographs
um
the predominant design of housing is
this one plot Number Two
um that has
dual pitched roof and side Gables so
um however on the photo you can also see
larger dwellings built to the
south of the side
as you can see on this photo here so
they're slightly larger
to the ones that you can see on the for
on the foreground and
the different design of plot Number One
um was requested by me to overcome
to basically overcome the issue of
potential loss of light to the property
that is located to the north
so because the change to the roof design
um
the change to the roof design on plot
one
um
resulted in the in this dwelling to meet
the standards
um
of impacts on the residential amenity
and although this design is slightly
different to what is in the area I also
considered I can show you a photograph
of the street scene
so for example on
here you can see a Starbucks Road and
these properties are to the north of the
side
and the proposed dwelling would
on plot number one would be located here
and the roof line although the overall
design would be slightly different to
what is in the area the the roof line
this different roof line of plot one
would follow the roof Lines within
Starboard Road which would essentially
harmonize better in the street scene as
seen from Starbucks within starboard
throat
okay do we have any more points for
clarity oh sorry cancel Crump has stuck
his hand up oh crocky everyone is now
councilor Crump makes me just just a
couple of brief ones Mr chairman uh
firstly on page 70 it says that building
regulations will be able to secure
um suitable drainage for the site
um so that meets that requirement
and second the the SPD regarding
highways and parking we've reached our
minimum
there's just some little bit which says
I know the highway Authority wasn't able
to ascertain whether the sizes of the
proposed carbon car parking spaces are
sufficient as no Dimensions were shown
on the submitted plans so therefore do
we still meet those minimum parking
requirements
cancer Kettle just to inform you I have
seen you you can stop waving your hand
now we're going to finish off everyone
speaking and asking questions and then
I'll come to you
so
um sorry what was the first question was
what were there two questions or just
one was always satisfied that the
building regulations will be able to
provide sufficient flooding
um alleviation to to make uh alleviate
any problem and the second one was to do
with the minimum requirements parking
requirements SPD but there was a query
regarding the dimensions and the
highways Authority would so I'll be
still meeting that SPD okay uh so
um to respond to your first question
um that drainage will be
um sufficient drainage will be provided
through the building regulations and
also currently the site is basically
just hard standing and the proposed
residential Gardens would essentially
help to ease that problem because there
would be most likely grass or just you
know
um so the drainage would be
um I assume would be essentially
improved as a result of the development
and to respond to your second question
about parking I measured the proposed
spaces and the the widths of the garage
doors and it Accords with our standards
so sufficient parking will be provided
for both of the dwellings
thank you thanks for writing next please
councilor Mills did I see your hand go
up and we'll come back to council do we
know is it are they open market housing
or is it going straight back to I
couldn't see are they
orbit open uh yes I believe there are
Market housing okay thank you it was
assessed as Market housing
counselor are you ready for me to come
back to you or shall I wait
I think
okay did I see a hand come up over this
side Council cases did you stick your
hand off a minute okay you got anyone
else got any points of clarification
now cancer cattle you've stuck your hand
up just to remind you that we can only
call you forward for uh to clarify a
point of fact is that what you're coming
to clarify if you're going to speak I
need you to speak into a microphone but
I need you to confirm that it's going to
be clarifying a point of fact
yeah
okay
um the question was asked by councilor
Harvey as to whether there are any other
similar properties to these two being
proposed
um I mentioned this is part of the Laken
driver state where all the properties
have been almost identical vernacular
obviously with more detail than the
bigger properties compared to smaller
ones the planning officer has related to
a different estate which faces in a
different direction that is somewhere
way where again all those properties
they're different they can drive estate
but there is a similar vernacular among
all those in that estate there is
nowhere in this part of the village in
fact there is nowhere in the whole
village where you've had two properties
parachuted into a small spare of
spare patch
um as councilor Harvey asked it does it
has not happened anywhere else in this
Village every other property matches the
local vernacular of its estate
okay thank you very much
okay we got any more points of
clarification before we move into
debates no let's move to the debates
who'd like to kick us off Council Dixon
please
thank you chairman uh I think we've all
uh come across all but uh selling off
its garages and uh houses being created
and built on such plots and it's always
a great sadness to lose those parking
options
but I think these parking options have
already gone
um the residents aren't parking there
now they are already forced under the
streets so whether or not two houses go
under that plot or not that land is no
longer a car park and it's no longer a
facility for garaging of cars
um now councilor Kettle made great
reference to the design aspects uh have
the two detached houses don't fit into
the the terracing effect of What were
ex-council houses built in the 1970s
well I don't know how you can actually
create terracing
um which would therefore meet the design
of the local housing and my recollection
of 1970s and looking at the photographs
um that's nothing to be repeated to my
mind
um so I'm minded to go along with the
officer's recommendation and propose
that we actually Grant permission
chairman
thank you very much Council Dixon I
wasn't actually alive in the 70s so I'm
glad you you can remind us all about it
Council Mills is next on my list please
yes thanks Mr
um Miss Jim I I do have some sympathies
with counselor kettle on this one we've
got the same yeah the same situation in
Kyneton uh orbit
um
have stopped people parking where the
garbages are they're doing it all around
uh the district
I do believe that all of it have a duty
of care to the residents
um I I can't support this because
um
I obviously didn't support the last
application came in for Clinton so I'll
be quite duplicitous on that so uh I
can't support the
resist recommendation on this Mr
chairman thank you just one Claire are
you making a counter proposal to refuse
and if you are I I'll come back to you
for reasons in a second okay yeah you
are making accounts proposal to refuse
I'll come back to you for reasons if we
need them uh cancer Kendall next please
thank you chairman um I'll be as quick
as I can I I don't I think the question
of poor design is highly subjective and
as Council Dixon says I don't see how
you'd manage to come up with some sort
of terrorist plan in this location
anyway
um the parking is already gone I think
this is a logical infill I'm happy to
Second the proposal to Grant thank you
very much Council Adam please
thank you um I'm more sympathetic to
council mills's point of view on this I
think I
I must say I mean I
terracing aside I'm not impressed by the
design particularly the garage right in
front of the front door
um I think slightly more egregious I'm
also not comfortable with the fact that
the garage on the other side which is
adjacent to another boundary has that
Gable end there if it were
a do a pitch or a lean two in the other
direction it might have a less impactful
sort of Shadow but I think particularly
with somebody who uses a south facing
Garden myself I find that that would no
way that that couldn't have an impact on
lighting
um I
on top of that I mean I know we sort of
say every time it comes up I'm still not
happy about the over development of
of our settlements and I know we keep
going back to this same
um
the inspectors uh report comment which
I've seen a number of times but I mean I
know Bishop's hitchington and it has had
a huge amount of development and the
satellite development near it has does
count towards that and the the
development of the area
um and the the amenities that they
require I think that the the in my
reading of that the the vernacular used
approximately and around is used as a
justification for allowing development I
think it can also be used conversely uh
in that we can say fairly definitively
that
um a doubling of uh of a number is not
around the number that was intended
um
I I'm really not comfortable with this
based on how it is I think there are
infills that work on these sites I don't
like them necessarily but you know we do
see them I think the parking issue is
one that I am concerned about as well
particularly as the garages and even the
parking spaces aren't sized
um for the highways authority to uh to
really comment on I'm happy to Second
councilman mills's
proposal to to refuse and if we need
more uh robust reasoning then I'm happy
to try and provide that as well thank
you okay thank you just so um we're
clear we have the proposal to Grant uh
with second did prior to your seconding
of the proposal for you so that will be
the vote we have first if that fails I
will then make sure that we get our full
reasoning from the two of you okay uh
Council Curtis next please thank you
very much
um councilor Adam has been extremely
eloquent uh grew pretty much every
everything he's said and but
particularly about the overbearing
nature
Over the Garden of that North garage and
that doesn't seem to have been fully the
nature of that
doesn't seem to have been fully taken
into account in the officer's report I
think it's more serious than is alluded
to in the report
okay thank you councilor Harvey I'm
inclined to support Council Dixon's
point of view the
the question of parking the the
statements from the case officer and
Council ketler are diametrically opposed
it's it strikes me that the parking has
been lost uh the parking that's required
generated by these two houses is
self-contained within the site this site
has to be used for something the end the
the neighborhood development plan uh
supports Housing Development it's within
the built-up area boundary we can have a
discussion about design the officer has
considered it and you could argue that
it's almost impossible to put a design
together that fits in with a series of
terrorist houses you could make the
argument that these two sites these two
properties sit better with the
properties to the South
um
it may not be a perfect application it
may be it may not be an ideal solution
but on balance I take the point of view
it's it merits support
okay thank you very much um anyone else
before we go to a vote okay so the
proposal is to a grant in line with the
officer recommendation made by Council
Dixon seconded by cancer Kendall can I
have a show of hand footage in favor of
granting please
six and those against
three committee therefore results to
Grant application
2203314 ful garage blocks um at stubble
Road in Bishops itchington now members
we've been going for an hour and 45
minutes
um I've drunk too much coffee so we are
going to have a two minute uh pit stop
and we'll be back here as quickly as
possible please
okay members thank you very much for
indulging me there oh we will move to
our last item oh excuse me which is
um application reference
2202408 ful and
2202409 LBC uh this is uh in warmington
um and our presenting officer is once
again malwina
I've lost money
okay so um this application is
um for planning permission and a listed
building content
um for an extension
um
to a dwelling known as the dean in
wormington here on this slide you can
see the application site in The Wider
context
the site is washed over by the
conservation area and aonb designations
and as you can see on this location plan
this is the main property which is great
to list it
and it also includes
um part of the listed range here however
the works are proposed to the main
dwelling it is proposed to demolish the
existing single story extensions to the
rear entry place with a two-story
extension
here you can see the aerial view of the
site
and on this slide we can see the
existing site plan on the left hand side
you can see the single story extension
there
and on the right hand side and this is
the proposed extension this element here
is to story and it also has
two single story flat roof extensions
one to one side and one on the other
on this slide you can see
um
the existing and proposed elevations
so
here you can see the existing elevation
this is the front of the main house and
the existing single story extension
and this is the rear elevation you can
see the single story extensions and
existing extensions are there
and at the bottom on the left hand side
this is how the proposed extension
um would appear from the as seen from
the front of the property and this is
how it would look
a sin from within the rear Garden
here you can see the site elevations
so this is the existing extensions here
and at the bottom you can see the
proposed to story extension and here you
can see the flat roof element
and the proposed west elevation as seen
there with the flat roof element
between the main dwelling and the
two-story extension
so this is the main property as seen
from the front you can see that this
Eastern elevation
would be seen within the street scene
you can see the existing single story
elements there and the proposed to story
extension would be visible
in the streets in
but not from the unlikely from the other
side
this is the existing single story
extension
as seen from
um within the drive
and this is the existing rear elevation
the extension would be located here
and this is another
um view towards the rear elevation
um and the case officer recommended the
applications both for planning
permission and for the listed building
constant to be refused
um
the council's conservation officer
considered that the proposed extension
is not acceptable and would cause harm
to the Heritage assets
and it was also considered that the
proposed Extensions by reason of their
scale would be inappropriate and also
the other recommended the other refusal
of reason is on design grounds
thank you malawina thank you very much
indeed our first and only speaker on
this item is Council Fielding Council
Fielding do come forward please
you will have five minutes you'll give
you a 30 second winning before your time
is up use as much or as little of the
five minutes as you wish once you're sat
comfortable and ready to go press the
button on the right and I will start the
timer
canceling if you're going to speak would
you mind turning your microphone on and
as I said I will give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up if I am
under time can you please let me know I
can let I will let you know
right
the bill the building has been altered
and enlarged over the course of
centuries it was built in the 17th
century
with an 18th century ex Edition and in
the 1990s the property was enlarged
again with an extension running at right
angles to the 18th century Edition
The Proposal is to replace the external
staircase
that runs outside the building which the
conservation officer doesn't like the
new extension will accommodate a passage
between the first floor of the 18th
century and the and the first floor
bedroom area at the back of the building
the staircase referred to will be
enclosed within the extension and we re
realigned to give access to the first
floor
a new access from the first floor of the
18th century extension is
to
um to a new extension will be formed by
removing a window
this opening will be enlarged to provide
a doorway between the two parts of the
building
the accommodation
replacement sorry to accommodate the
requirements of the case conservation
officer glass panels will be
incorporated in the walls of the
extension so the existing Stern work
will be visible the applicant's agent
has gone along with the planning
officer's comments about reducing the
size of the extension particularly the
size of the new bedroom area
the planning officer states that cs9 the
development proposal will be sensitive
to the settings and the existing
building form and will reflect the
extent context of the location she
states that the general generous size of
the garden that also includes a swimming
pool
and overall distance from the
neighboring developments ensures that
despite the size of the proposed
extension no neighbors neighboring
residents will be impacted on the
extension
therefore she considers in accordance
with cs9 and 20 of the strategy
however in her conclusion
she states that the proposals fail to
comply with
sdp and also cs9 and cs20
with regards to all grade two listed
buildings one must prove that there is
less than substantial harm
that the public benefits because and the
public benefits become important the
nppf paragraph 7 and the PPG state that
anything which delivers economic social
and environment objectives of
sustainability development as described
in the nppf should be taken into account
the
ppeg States clearly that the public
benefits must flow from the development
and must be of a nature of scale that
would benefit the public at large but
those benefits do not always have to be
visible or accessible to the public or
to all sections of the public to be a
genuine public benefit
thus less than substantial harm must be
considered the public benefits sorry
thus less than substantial harm must
consider the public benefits derived
from the development I would therefore
argument argue that the ex
extending the dean and the building of a
new extension meets the above criteria
the social benefits to an applicant
that enjoys entertaining and having a
number of people coming to stay
the environmental
improvements to climate change improving
insulation and a more easily manageable
property thus I ask that this be granted
there are no
additional objections apart from one of
the
parish councilors who has put no reps in
hence one of the reasons why there is no
Parish councilors coming in support
apart from that there are no objections
from any of the neighbors the in my view
that the extension is
in 30 seconds
and will improve the well-being and the
accommodation within a
house where the existing bedrooms are of
an ancient design
you asked me to say how much time you
got left you've got 11 seconds and 19
milliseconds do you want to use them
good okay members do we have any
questions for our Ward member please
Castle Mills
John
um you said the the existing extension
when was that built
1919.
right
John can I put your microphone on please
apologies yeah I've tried to find it
okay it's in the paperwork that they
were in 99
um where they got permitted conditions
and listing building approval you say 19
or 90 90.
but the application went forward I think
I think the question's been answered now
because anyone else have any questions
for cancer Fielding
no council building thank you very much
your time and contribution this evening
members do we have any points of
clarification for our officers please
councilor Harvey
thank you chairman
um public benefit in your report sorry
councilor Harvey I'm going to ask you to
turn your microphone towards you thank
you very much in your report you make
reference to public benefit only once
and that's in your conclusion as far as
I could see
um
given that there is harm being caused to
a listed building
there needs to be some element of public
benefit in order to compensate for that
harm
is the absence of your mention of public
benefits in your report a reflection of
the fact that you think there are none
or if you think there are some what
might they be
so just to clarify marvina wasn't the
case officer so she didn't write the
report she's just presenting the item
which is well I'll answer the question
but but yes essentially the fact that
the officer hasn't gone into detail in
terms of public benefits in the main
body and has just concluded that there
aren't any
um is because officers do not consider
there to be public benefits sufficient
to outweigh that harm
um it's to my mind a solely private
benefit there may be some minor economic
benefits from
um construction employment in the short
term so that would be a public benefit
but to my mind would be given limited
way and certainly wouldn't outweigh the
harm that the conservation conservation
officer has identified
QED
cancer Curtis please thank you and just
two points if I if I may well we're not
on that photo that you're showing there
with your cursor could you just sort of
outline where the sort of height of the
proposed extension would go
and just a
um so um can you see the cursor I'm not
saying not really sure
um so so the extension would um
would go to the
just up there
right okay so yeah and my and actually
you may not be able to answer there's no
I'm sometimes I get easily confused
um on page eight
um
just picking up one of the points that's
been made
I'm slightly confused because at the top
of page 80 the report which I appreciate
isn't your report it says the proposals
are therefore considered to appall with
policies cs9 and cs20
four or five paragraphs further down and
it says the proposal fails to record
with policies CSA and uh size cs9 and
cs20 now I know obviously different
policies are given different weight but
I was slightly confused by how it can
both Accord and not Accord with those
two policies can you explain that to me
please yeah absolutely so policy cs9
um includes both design and the visual
sense and also residential amenity so
where we're staying at the top of page
80 that it complies with policy cs9
that's in respect to the residential
immunity aspect so we think the impact
on residential immunity is acceptable
where we're talking about a conflict of
cs9 and the conclusion relates to the
design impacts which are considered to
be unacceptable and that's further set
out and the reasons for that set out are
in the design and distinctive section of
the report on page 79 so we're basically
saying we don't think the design is okay
but we think residential amenity is so
there's a partial conflicts partial
compliance thank you for the excellent
explanation
thank God Alice is here that's all I can
say
any other questions for clarifying
members no let's move to debate who'd
like to kick us off councilor Harvey
please
this is to me absolutely straightforward
this is a proposal which causes harm to
a listed building we have a statutory
obligation under the 1990 act to take
that into account there are the officers
have not provided any discernible public
benefits to offset this harm the
application cannot receive my support
just to be clear that's a proposal to
refuse a proposal to refuse thank you
very much councilor admin please
thank you chair
um yeah the plan is
um to replace or part of a beautiful
house with another beautiful looking
house however
um I don't see any public benefits the
conservation office or in their
professional opinion
judges it to be harmful and overly
dominant
um and if it wasn't listed I'd love it
but we need to treat these things as
antiques
so I'm happy on this occasion to go with
the officers recommendation and second
councilor Harvey fabulous thanks very
much cancer Curtis no anyone else
in that case let's make sure a votes
proposal is uh now just I want to be
absolutely clear this is on the ful and
we'll come to the LBC in a second so on
the ful The Proposal is to refuse in
line with us for recommendation made by
accounts Harvey seconded by cancer
Edmond could I have a sheriff hands for
those in favor of refusing please
that is unanimous uh so committee
therefore resolves to refuse application
2202408 ful now on the LBC councilor
Harvey can I assume that you are
prepared to propose the refusalem with
office recommendation again correct and
Council head into second of course
marvelous unless anyone else wants to
say anything we will go for a vote so
again proposal is to uh refuse in line
with the office of recommendation made
by councilor Harvey secondly by cancer
Adam could have hands please in favor
refusal please that is unanimous a
committee therefore resolves two refuse
application
2202-409 LBC
um I don't believe we have any urgent
business no in that case members thank
you very much for your time uh officers
thank you for your time contributions
and of course for all our speakers as
well we'll see in a couple of weeks
thanks very much
thank you